Hey how's it going huh I know what
you're thinking well will their babies
look like well we're gonna explore that
today breasts
the first suggestion comes from Eve and
semi-custom wants to see Tom Cruise and
Will Smith what will their babies look
like well Simic sometimes there's just
some questions that you shouldn't
[ __ ] and ask but now I need to find
out yes yes baby yes baby sex and sex
instruct me and you do the kind of strip
that only pins but think about something
Joe hey I've down my pants and I bet you
feel this cuz I was like baby baby baby
oh like baby baby baby oh like baby baby
baby
well then it looks like if Tom Cruise
and Will Smith had a baby
it's the spawn of Satan I don't know how
we did not see this before this gusting
kelan kelan kelsey Kate wanted to see
Kanye West and Sarah Jessica Parker oh
my god I know already this is gonna be
awful awfully beautiful so she can serve
chic so she can show G oh my god oh my
god it does not look that bad to be
honest but this is magic but it's this
sorcery let's go down to this tennis
court and talk get out I need stop
singing I'm sorry I feel bad for this
baby I really do
it got a nightmare like this one once
I think it ended with the destruction of
mankind it seriously looked like
something that came out of [ __ ] hell
well there you have it yo I got some
questions you just should not answer
Abigail a pot Agosto wants to know
harmonii and hagrid the [ __ ] is wrong
with my fans
okay
it looks like a sama bin Laden's ghost
or some [ __ ]
Agron and Hermione you're meddling in
things that ought not to be meddled in
all right moving on with this [ __ ]
thing Tyrion it renews your why why am I
talking like this sorry I'm sorry Tom
Cruise and tell miss the train I want to
see me and tell miss a train you know
what I'm gonna change it do me and tough
as a dragon I want to see what what true
the face of true evil looks like it
looks like it wears a mask of death and
suffering and horrible things like taxes
okay let's get some ships in here
because let's be honest here that's how
I make my living
okay this is a good one
Justin Bieber and Voldemort by Kristen
Doyle
load hold too much
more load Voldemort Lord Voldemort I
don't know what I'm about to do but I'm
pretty sure it's not holy
oh my job never have I been so sexually
conflicted before in my entire life what
the hell am I looking at man it's some
sexy [ __ ]
all right press we have time for one
more and one more only what is it gonna
be Katy Perry and the rock Johnson Jesus
Christ calm down man now let's add a
little touch of Katy Perry gdg DNA oh my
god look at that face you look like my
next mistake well then well then that is
Katy Perry and Dwayne the rock Johnson
in case they had a baby now I'm glad we
investigated the rock I'm glad we
investigated that one I'm really glad we
we went there Dwayne Wes you're sure
hurt Dwayne is shirtless drain do it
shirtless where's your shirt Dwayne
Dwayne is shirtless
I bet Dwayne is thinking right now
where's my shirt wish I had a shirt man